you know just yesterday we talked about
the definition of freedom that the right
adheres to right now
is very authoritarian the freedom to
deny other people things the freedom to
tell others what it is they can and
can't do
the freedom you know we talked about
that yesterday um there's another
element to this authoritarian slide that
i i think deserves its own discussion
which is that the republican party is
moving in the direction of pulling out
of future presidential debates the
republican national committee says it
will require candidates to pledge to not
participate in debates run by the
commission on presidential debates what
would replace them if anything was
unclear
this is an extraordinarily authoritarian
move now there's sort of like the
logical reason why they would do this
and then there's the reality that it
fits into this bigger authoritarian
picture and we'll go through both of
those aspects in a second the new york
times reporter maggie haberman reported
the rnc is preparing to change its rules
to require presidential candidates that
want to be a republican nominee to
pledge not to participate in what have
historically been the official
presidential debates
sponsored by the commission on
presidential debates republican
committee officials alerted the debate
commission to their plans in a letter
sent thursday
if the change goes forward it would be
one of the most substantial shifts in
how presidential and vice presidential
debates have been conducted since the
commission began organizing debates more
than 30 years ago
the nonprofit commission was founded by
the two parties in 1987. it codified
debates as a permanent part of
presidential elections describes itself
as nonpartisan republicans have
complained for a decade that the process
favored democrats
the move by the rnc was an outgrowth of
those long held complaints and came
after months of discussions between the
commission and party officials
this discussion apparently started last
year
the republican party chairwoman ronna
mcdaniel demanded changes be made to how
debates were held the change requiring
candidates to refuse participation is to
be voted on at the rnc winter meeting in
february if they move forward it's
unclear what that means for future
debates so there are two pieces to this
okay first let's talk about the sort of
like well yeah
if you have no issue based platform on
which you would debate
why would you debate and what i mean by
that is increasingly
started with i mean listen i'm not going
to do the whole thing but it this
started a really long time ago but more
acutely
george w bush became less and less issue
focused and more kind of ideology based
when barack obama became president
republicans went completely crazy and
abandoned policy 90
and then under trump there's been no
more policy at all if you don't have
policy on which to debate why would you
go to a debate okay that that sort of
makes sense but then it goes further if
you're not trying to win on the issues
right if you're winning on trying to win
on gerrymandering voter suppression
bogus post-election tactics legal
challenges and the like
debates don't really have a part in that
you don't really need to convince people
to vote for you
and the third piece of this is that this
is very on brand in terms of being
autocratic and authoritarian and former
david pakman show guest guest ruth ben
giat wrote a really good piece in her
sub stack called demagogues don't debate
the gop mimics putin and orban refusing
to participate in presidential debates
is a symptom of the republicans embrace
of authoritarianism this is a really
good article to check out a good blog
post from ruth ben giat
who writes debates between presidential
candidates enact the democratic
principle of mutual tolerance the notion
that those who don't share your
political views have a right to free
expression the public hears an exchange
of views by two individuals on equal
footing bound by the same rules and
forced by an impartial arbiter when they
say we're not going to do that anymore
it furthers this idea that number one
they people with political disagreements
can't even be in the same room as each
other
but also
is the
furtherance of other aspects of
authoritarianism personality cults as
ruth ben giat writes posit the leader as
a man above all others the egalitarian
staging and format of debates makes them
dangerous to his brand since
authoritarians sustain power through
disinformation threat corruption and
fixing elections who knows what might be
exposed if they submit to spontaneous
questioning by a rival or a third party
and that is a fundamental aspect of this
and i won't read ruth's entire post but
she talks about putin understanding this
and his history of refusing to debate
and talks about orban a putin client who
has followed that lead orban hasn't
debated since 16 years ago
after a really bad performance in a 2006
debate so there's two aspects of this
and there's the
they don't run on policy so why even
talk to the opposition sure that's fair
but then there's also yet another way
in this which
in which this idea of not getting on
stage with your opponent
mimics and mirrors that which we've seen
other authoritarian strong men do
around the world over the last 20 years
so very much on brand with this extreme
authoritarian
dictatorial slide that we've seen from
the republican party the republican
party will vote next month as to whether
they are finalizing this decision not to
participate in the debates
my instinct is they're going to do it
i don't think this you know it seems
like the type of thing they would kind
of decide beforehand do we have the
votes for it but we'll see next month
and we'll tell you when there is an
ultimate decision made by them in the
meantime you can let me know your
thoughts about this wildly autocratic
decision
by finding me on twitter deepakman